Music
You can do hackathons which are 24 hour events.
You can work in a team and build a project you might have come up with the idea yourself.
A company might have wanted a project to be done and at the end they usually get evaluated.
You might win something.
There's also capture the flags which you can do if you're interested in security.
You can also do things such as spring insight weeks if you're in university which companies offer to let you know about their company and what the working world is like.
There's also summers of code and things like that you can do outside of uni.
You can also get involved in tech meetups and go to career events.
So a lot of companies will be there because they're recruiting people.
And it's a great way to get to know people in the industry and make connections which will definitely help you outside of university as well.
Outside of tech at university you can get involved in whatever societies you want to join.
So for me I joined calligraphy society which is quite niche and it's quite different to tech.
But it was a really good way to kind of explore my creative side which is something that is sometimes not really looked upon in tech even though tech can be quite creative.
But I think it actually did help me with the computer science side of things as well.
I guess for me one of the interesting things that I've been able to be involved in is participating in the Women in Tech campaign and the scholarship that we launched last year at Portugal.
Obviously coming from a different background to everyone here it was really interesting and it led us to get the three of you which was really lovely.
Just wanna be me!